[Applause]
happy
tuesday everyone
so much fun
so let's talk about roe versus wade
i'm kidding
[Applause]
i gotcha let's talk about a different
abortion
no no no one performed on a story
by the media
see what i did there i tricked you twice
because it seems every day we find more
proof of how corrupt the press is in
killing off a living breathing story out
of convenience it was a group effort
strangling a breakthrough expose that
would have changed the landscape of an
election
the press along with dems facebook and
twitter took the laptop story to their
own version of planned parenthood and
suffocated it with a high-tech blanket
the latest bombshell remember how joe
biden claims he never spoke to hunter
about his dealings with the chinese
true they talked mostly about crack
cocaine on the 15-hour flight
on air force two but now we know that
story is as false as joe's teeth
he knew what hunter was up to
trying to make it rain with
multi-million dollar chinese companies
and after seeing the new york times
piece about chinese corruption online
joe called hunter and told him it was
all cool
you have a chance to give me a call
nothing urgent
i just want to talk to you about the
article at least has been on online it's
going to be printed one time it's good
i need to clear
ah clear
those were the days ah
when joe could still pronounce words
now i'd call that call a smoking gun but
then hunter would try to puff it
so what's that say really well that the
president's denials were more fully
a toilet at taco bell
he did discuss hunter's shady dealings
with his son and he knew enough from
hunter to worry about this new york
times piece because the piece featured
certain shady people hunter was trying
to do business with using his daddy's
name
so while the media had everyone chasing
the steele dossier which involved made
up russian prostitutes donald trump and
bed sheets paved with gold
there were actual real russian
prostitutes making a killing off hunter
biden which was financially covered by
pop
that according to the washington times
yeah it appears president biden paid for
his sons frolicks with an escort ring
based in russia before he became
president
and i gotta say what a cool dad
yeah all my dad got me was a baseball
glove and a schwinn
i mean don't get me wrong i love the
glove and the bike but it's no hookers
dad
no wonder i stopped growing
oh everybody in my block got hookers i
got a bike
anyway it's being reported that joe paid
for the sex inadvertently but doesn't
joe do everything inadvertently
he's the mr magoo of presidents
the guy so clueless people from his son
to woke staffers can run scams on him
from morning to night
even the teens at baskin robbins have
been putting mayonnaise in his cone and
telling him it's french vanilla
just for a laugh
and i'm fairly certain joe is the only
person to have actually returned a phone
call about his lap's car insurance
[Laughter]
in this case the times reports that joe
wired his son 100 grand to help him pay
bills from december 2018 to january 2019
that's six figures in just a few months
but in fairness to hunter you know how
expensive organic kale eggs and chicken
is at whole
whole foods
and also there's the horse
they're more expensive than gluten-free
boxed water
which is why i cut back
on the water
but it makes you view the steel dossier
in a different light now do you see why
it was pushed so hard and why the press
refused to let it go it was all a
diversion from the real stuff this stuff
the dossier was a decoy from the real
sex scandal which has always been a
typical democratic strategy if they are
guilty of something really bad they will
accuse you of it first well before you
have time to figure out it was them
doing it all along you know it's why i
keep accusing my wife of wearing my
underwear
yeah
so what
that means he's wearing her underwear
good job columbo
so while democrats and media obsess over
one day in january they don't want you
interested in how those protesters ended
up there why they were angry that's a
root cause they won't chase because it
leads right back to them and their
corruption and their collusion january 6
came from a sense that we were all being
screwed by institutions working together
you know what time magazine happily
called a cabal remember they boasted
about swaying the election afterwards
so many of the protesters behave badly
they broke the law and they will pay for
it but their overarching instincts about
saving the country from a corrupt system
is the product of sanity
that's why the hunter biden laptop story
scares the media so much it proves so
many people right it was a bombshell
story buried under mutual agreement
between the most powerful entities in
america and if you brought the story up
you'd be fitted for a tin foil hat in
minutes thrown off social media and
labeled a crazed conspiracy theorist
and the goal to get the guy out that
they hated so much and bring in the
feeble old man they could control behind
the scenes like a human drone
all it takes are note cards and a few
pallets it depends
the aviator glasses are to hide when
he's unconscious
so the rest was history corrupt insane
history that led to this force feeding
of january 6 hearings that offers more
rhinos than an african safari
[Music]
suddenly the hearing becomes part of the
bigger picture it's not an investigation
it's the cherry on a profoundly corrupt
cake after four years of fake collusion
attacks on trump supporters branding
millions as deplorably racist pile after
pile of fake news this was the coup de
gras which i think is french for a kick
in the balls
which is something hunter probably
ordered
and his dad ended up paying for
let's welcome
tonight's guests
he'll make pelosi sob when he takes her
job house minority leader kevin mccarthy
we have to make this show quick because
her tractor is double parked out front
fox business anchor dagin mcdowell
[Applause]
and he is often mistaken for a magician
since his act makes audiences disappear
actor writer comedian jamie lissau
and she's like a set of car keys small
sharp and gets lost in your sofa fox's
contributor cat tip
leader mccarthy
are you nuts coming on this show
are you already regretting it do you
feel that perhaps the advice given to
you to do this show was bad advice
no one gave me advice to do it that's
the problem
my daughter texted me before i got a
text from my daughter she says i think
we should talk before you go on the show
no it's a true text did she give you any
advice
she said don't try to be funny
the best
advice anybody could give anybody
whether you're funny or not because the
pers we've had guests on here that come
on here that think they're funny they're
oh and they're and it's painful i mean
jamie
[Music]
but you know he's he's part of the
make-a-wish foundation so it's like we
have to like you know
the problem is he's not dying he's not
dying he's not dying
they did the we were told a year ago yes
the foundation they just felt bad for
yeah so he gets to go to disneyland to
do this show why are we hazing you
okay you become speaker do we do
anything do we and i say we people piss
off about hunter is there some kind of
investigation that will take place
well there has to be from all purposes
right but but
when you read it's funny but it's sad
think about that it was government it
was social networks it was newspapers
all saying this was wrong and then you
also had the head of the intel committee
think about this adam's shift this is a
guy that gets all the secrets right they
sat there and told us this was all farce
yeah you know i mean you could make a
joke you could say yeah i understand why
the president thinks his son is the
smartest man in the world he got his
father to pay for the hookers and you
know he got he
that is smart yeah but then he got the
whole country to protect him at the same
time yes so that's it is it could you
could you imagine if donald trump any
one of his kids did one tenth or one
thing like that no it's a yeah it's
incredible no it would be they would
have hearings on that
which makes leads me to my
fantasy and it is a fantasy degan
not the one you not the one i told you
about earlier
that's between you and me and hr
the uh
so you had like we're on like our second
week of january 6. can you imagine how
much more interesting
a two-week hearing would be on hunter
biden do you know the numbers would be
huge
yes i mean you've got crack you got meth
you got sex you got terrible tattoos
i if
y'all do hearings all i ask is that you
use a screen about the size of this room
and you don't blur anything out
[Laughter]
because i've not been able to look up
unblurred photos of hunter biden here at
work well remember the democrats hired
this guy from abc yes
and you know two years prior i sent a
letter because this is the same man that
kept all the stuff about epstein
quiet yep so i figure if we have these
hearings we hire greg yeah there you go
all right
i can't
i already got a job i already got a job
to your point yes
why don't more people volunteer for the
hunter biden beat i i put my hand up
right now yes i don't know i am fluent
in
grifter scumbag i learned how to speak
it in my 20s yeah
and i i
love dumpster diving behind somebody's
house uh you know going through
somebody's garbage is not beneath me and
can you imagine what you would find in
hunter biden's garbage yeah like
crumpled up 20 bills yes set of car
music
keys
a gun literally
literally a gun
uh and he plays his pat okay
jamie um you know i know as a recently
divorced man i know that you wish you
could live the life of hunter biden yeah
yeah and like but i feel like he needs
to do a little more like price shopping
right that's a lot of money for escorts
yeah it was like 30 000
that's more than it costs that i've ever
spent on escort and i used to own a ford
escort
that's a lot of money yeah i do feel a
lot of time inside that i did spend a
lot yeah
if you work it out over five months it's
not that much money i did the math he's
only hiring an escort um two and a half
times a week
five months that's just really that's
not even close to my record yeah it is
it's just i feel a little bad for joe
he's getting completely taken advantage
of when hunter says he's using the
hundred thousand dollars for bills
the only way that's true is if hunter
has two pimps each one of them named
bill
[Laughter]
that was good and did did you he was i
think i don't know if he was giving him
an allowance of like 75 100 a week right
but before we're so quick to judge maybe
he was doing like like really big chores
yeah that's true
that's a big lawn in delaware maybe he
was on diaper duty yeah
no one's asked him now with inflation
how much more he has to give them that's
true that's true but i think if you
become president what does it cost
hunter biden now yeah exactly 100 bucks
should be complaining about the
inflation rate on paid escorts that's
right
because it is going up am i right cat
yep almost went into danger zone there
did you notice okay he films everything
did you see the two-minute clip i sent
around to him like brow beating a paid
escort as he paid her it was incredible
it was like he had the phone on going
like what did i do do you have any
bruises it was just so pathological and
strange what do you make of this this
weird obsession of filming everything
ah
yeah
not much
i don't know because like there's
there's probably so much more but at
this point what could there be we'd be
like whoa okay yeah
we've already seen him do everything
uh and again it's not the stuff that
bothers me i don't care how many hookers
he bangs
uh i don't care who pays for the hookers
that he bangs and you know i i wouldn't
do it
but um
good for you it's the well i don't even
like i don't even know him so yeah yeah
exactly
uh but like it's the corruption stuff
and that is the concerning stuff and i
think it's just so interesting that joe
biden is so old he got busted because he
left a voicemail
[Laughter]
can i add something this is a voicemail
why did hunter save that voicemail from
his dad why does he save everything but
he films every like i'm not kidding why
would
i get okay you're pervert you film the
the crazy sex you don't film the pain
what kind of purpose he forgot to turn
off the camera that's probably it but
what if what if he was into it like
maybe the best part is paying him off
watch this
let's rewind that part this is when i
hand the money
cat was right he did sound old in the
voicemail he was like hunter it's your
dad pick up
all right
up next they canned him for prayers
after games but now their case went down
in flames hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else